[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a la ciudad
estadounidense de Nueva York porque
continuó el juicio contra Genaro García
Luna el secretario de seguridad pública
de México durante el gobierno de Felipe
Calderón el ex funcionario está acusado
de haber permitido las operaciones del
Cartel De Sinaloa a cambio de sobornos
vamos a conectar con mamen sala
corresponsal de Francia 24 vamos a ver
qué ocurrió durante esta segunda
audiencia
si así como la semana pasada se
eligieron esos 12 miembros del Jurado en
este proceso hoy hemos escuchado los
argumentos iniciales de ambas partes la
fiscalía ha centrado su primera
intervención en asegurar que Genaro
García Luna era una parte importante del
funcionamiento delictivo que tenía el
cartel de Sinaloa y por su parte los
abogados de García Luna han dicho que no
hay pruebas suficientes que demuestren
que su defendido recibió los sobornos a
García Luna se le acusa de cinco delitos
por haber pertenecido a una empresa por
haber traficado introducido millones de
kilos de cocaína en Estados Unidos y
también por mentir a las autoridades en
el 2018 para intentar conseguir la
nacionalidad estadounidense en la segura
que es Inocente de todo lo que se le
está acusando pero la fiscalía tiene
hasta 70 testigos en este proceso para
demostrar lo contrario algunos de ellos
son traficantes estraficantes temidos
mexicanos hoy hemos visto al primero de
ellos que ha subido al estrado estamos
hablando del extraficante conocido como
El Grande hace referencia a sus dos
metros de altura recordemos que formaba
parte del Clan de los Hermanos Beltrán
Leyva en el 2010 es detenido y pasa a
colaborar con las autoridades justo en
ese momento García Luna ocupa una
posición muy importante en México es el
secretario de seguridad pública Así que
como se pueden imaginar el Grande tenía
mucho que decir hoy y una de las
declaraciones más impactantes ha sido
que él mismo fue testigo de como uno de
los Hermanos Beltrán Leyva le entregaba
un trabajo de billetes en efectivo a
García Luna por un soborno dice que esto
se hacía de manera repetida y mensual a
lo largo de la semana Seguiremos
escuchando otros testimonios igual de
impactantes importantes para este
proceso que se espera que se alargue por
lo menos dos meses Amén pongamos en
contexto quienes Genaro García Luna y
cuál era su importancia dentro del
gobierno mexicano
Genaro García Luna era el encargado de
poner entre rejas a los narcotraficantes
mexicanos pero el que ha acabado sentado
en el banquillo de los acusados es él y
precisamente porque su nombre estuvo
relacionado con unas cajas unas maletas
llenas de dinero en efectivo durante el
juicio de Joaquín Guzmán conocido como
El chapo recordarán que se celebró entre
el 2018 y el 2019 Precisamente en esta
misma sala donde tiene lugar este
proceso y con el mismo juez Brian kogan
García Luna fue el secretario de
seguridad pública en México durante la
presidencia de Felipe Calderón entre el
2006 y el 2012 era el encargado de
luchar contra el narcotráfico de hecho
lanzó un plan muy agresivo que se
conoció como guerra contra las drogas
que acabó con un saldo de cerca de
250.000 Muertos pero al parecer y según
lo que estamos viendo en este proceso
por el día luchaba contra los
narcotraficantes pero por la noche
presuntamente Se estaría enriqueciendo
con sus sobornos cuando Felipe Calderón
termina ya su mandato el señor Genaro
García Luna viaja a da Texas Estados
Unidos allí permanece durante un tiempo
y en el 2019 cuando su nombre sale a
relucir en el juicio del Chapo la
policía empieza a investigarlo y lo
detiene en el 9 de diciembre del 2019 en
Dallas en Texas ocho días después lo
trasladan aquí a Nueva York a esperar su
juicio por el que dice que es inocente
se enfrenta a 20 años de prisión hasta
un máximo de cadena perpetua